et côté l'autre jour j'ai été appelé
pour te parler un tout petit peu de
l'émission qui aura comme invité tout ça
tu m'as dit que tu allais me parler de
ce qui se passe actuellement à paris oui
oui parce que malgré tout à paris ce
passe aussi des choses évidemment toi tu
voyage énormément tué aux quatre coins
du monde c'est vrai et puis tu passe
comme ça et je vois on a la chance
d'être avec toi et bien tu vois il se
passe à paris il ya des talents comme ça
qui s'ouvre un changement de genre et
bien et nous avons une trajet une une
comédienne avait non une tragédienne
c'est une c'est un personnage comme ça
qu'ils quitteraient très fort très qui
vraiment s'impose énormément depuis
quelques temps déjà et
ne bouffe pas vraiment grecque non non
m'a fait la joie des choses à la télé
comme ça très difficile et alors
maintenant elle chantait c'est
bouleversant c'est une sorte de rose une
rose épanouie et plus qu'une autre
excuse alice sapritch
[Musique]
on me demande si je suis heureux
c'est mon bonheur
c'est d'être
allez ça presse
c'est quelquefois je m'affiche
si j'ai créé dans mes mémoires
je suis une superstar
de normes on fume cigarette
à la manière d'un long septe
un long jour répond
je suis heureux
on me demande si je suis heureux
à la télé qui a joué les maires
monstrueux
[Musique]
aussi les maquis
vestri tease
il ne faut pas
[Musique]
et
maintenant
qu'elle chante
moi
j'ai
dit non au casino j'ai refusé de la
vierge les laisse à
vartan
après vu
mach est là
et moi
des mois
mois
que dirais tu
de l'enfer à
toi
pourquoi pas
sommes nous serons heureux
toi et moi
on dit que la boire ne tient pas ch
mais peu m'importe
est peu me chaut
la solitude
ça n'existe pas
or noir
car moi
je ne me quitte pas
alors je vous réponds
je suis heureux
vraiment
[Musique]
tout simplement
m
les cheveux
[Musique]
ça va coco pour le som
mes chers enfants
aujourd'hui nous ne ferons pas de
solfège à comme je le regrette en effet
par la circulaire numéro 32
1617 de monsieur l'inspecteur d'académie
j'ai été chargé officiellement
d'assurer les cours
d'éducation
sexuelle
voilà
ginette c'est fini
marcel tu veux que je te
dont la tradition populaire nous avait
enseigné que les petits garçons
naissaient dans les choux et les petites
filles dans les roues
vous le croyez
moi même je les crues
très longtemps
il n'en est rien on n'arrête pas de
problème
problème c'est un problème le papa
possède une grève qu'il veut offrir à la
maman
imaginez une crème et un pot de terre eh
bien le papa et le jardinier et la maman
et les faux
mais pour planter me direz vous il faut
où il faut ici il faut il faut il faut
il pas rares et il faut il faut il faut
il faut un clan toi
à ton avis mirel qui a le plantoir
commence à ton cousin gaza
mais nous maintenons papa aussi
mais non je ne les ai pas vus
tous les garçons ont un plantoir
c'est écrit
comme les coléoptères qui butine de
fleur en fleur ap ce n'est pas ça du
tout car nous sommes des mammifères
alors comment faire
comment le papa avec son plan toi
va-t-il planté
la graine
[Musique]
il y a pour cela 36 technique
jeu sa bulle
32 seulement
illégal il
y en a beaucoup trop
je vous serai tout ça
pour me retenir que la plus classique la
position dite à la papa
qui d'après ouvrage est la plus
reposante
mais attention la plume onat adouci de
gland thiémé viendrait me voir après le
court je vous ferai voir si c'est rigolo
pour planter il faut préparer le terrain
labourage et pâturage
sont en quelque sorte les deux mamelles
à propos de raml nous connaissions leur
primaire secondaire tertiaire
aujourd'hui nous connaissons nous que
nous
nous connaissons le l'érotisme
et moi j'ai l'air bête que je ne m'en
sortirais jamais tu dois vous dire que
pour les travaux pratiques
j'avais cru pouvoir compter sur la
collaboration
compétentes partie de votre professeur
de culture physique
monsieur tron chars
qui s'est récusé a bien fait pour lui
monsieur l'aumônier
de son côté est en partie en voyage de
noces
nous attendrons son retour pour en
savoir davantage
lanthier que mon doigt
pour conclure je vous citerai la phrase
du poète
puisque ces mystères nous échappe
feignons d'en être les organisateurs
autrement dit reportez vous à vos jours
nous habite
et pourrait révoquer esprits chantons
mais alors vraiment tout son coeur à
deux cibles ou savez-vous
[Musique]
progrès
une fois tout
petite blouse
et
pique elle était partie pour la terre
elle va atteindre cru
parce que c'était la mère de classe
[Rires]
[Musique]
j'étais d'abord ce n'était pas une
grenouille c'était un gros crac pour
tous des
débats le crapaud
tu vas te promener
il va au marché le crapaud et les
minions
[Musique]
manas
o mais tu vas te laver les mains
allô docteurs soir semi bonsoir doctor
who will be me met très bien très bien
mais très bien
très mal
pour le moment les croquis louis elle
écrase des crapauds
mais je pense bien mais je passe bien
faut pas la traumatiser
csu
jocelyne qu'est ce que tu fais
jocelyne qu'est ce que tu fais mais en
fallait sur le chien du fou
tu sais bien qu'ils n'aiment pas jouer
au rôti
tu scoop mais jusqu au prat que je
compromets
mais oui mais mais où m'écouter m'écoute
et me guider mes côtés dans l excès d
écouter
oui c'est sûr
jocelyne mais arrête dollars est de mort
tu vas dire qu'il n'est pas cuit nos
noms mais vous savez dr ya des fois où
comité de foire ou ya des fois où bien
des fois comme vous dites y'a les fois
où c'est sûr
à vrai dire docteur ce qui m'inquiète le
plus c'est le chant depuis qu'elle a
peint en rose ils n'osent plus sortir
comme vous dites il doit sortir
atteindre sa virilité
oui oui
vétérinaire c'est ça oui oui mais en
attendant je vais lui donner un valium
de la petite oui oui oui oui oui oui oui
oui
et bien c'est sans docteur écouter mes
amitiés à vendre votre bien et puis et a
attendu
mais
attendez
[Musique]
merci
donc cher maître en 35
j'ai épousé le colonel sigismond
bertrand de la brume
en 35 ans mais j'avais 17 ans a
alors en 38 que j'ai épousé le
commandant rené jérôme de montée de huy
par ce second mariage je suis devenue
madame de la brême ou de montée dont
deux larrons serait nous avons acheté la
roux serait attend dé 12 ans 39 oui
c'est ça à des étrangers qu'ils
préféraient partir suivre leurs étoiles
- t-il dit lord est
en 42 las de pleurer un deuxième vague
j'ai épousé un officier la fatalité à
sebha
veulent pas peur oui c'est sa chaire m
will elles me font pas peur alors là
vraiment la fatalité et puis en
44 il est parti en manoeuvre sur je ne
sais plus quelle plage normandie en juin
oui c'est sans joie 44 plus rien plus de
nouvelles alors je téléphone à l'hôtel
de la plage
il y avait que là qu'il pouvait être
défendu et on me répond
les carottes sont cuites
[Rires]
on m'avait pas c'est les cuisines
j'insiste pour chrome passe la réception
et j'entends baby vient le chercher
et bas j'y suis allé
mais pour le retrouver sur ce plat y
avait un mot vous pensez en juin la
pleine saison ou quoi autant chercher un
poisson rouge dans la mer noire
trois ans plus tard
mes cheveux ayant poussé
j'épouse et pierrot le corps a sacré
pied un chaud lapin celui-là a drôlement
résistant et puis en 51 j'ai enterré le
président a
très belle cérémonie y avait un monde et
raja et tout et tout bien sûr j'étais
toujours madame de la bresle ou de
montée dont de la roseraie mais j'étais
surtout madame la présidente le cac
alors j'ai coupé quelques rues d'angers
inauguré dès ouvrard des pouponnières
les pouponnières les pouponnières tout
ça en province
enfin
j'ai fait ma rentrée à paris en 58 j'ai
fait la connaissance d'un très grand
général
hélas il les fait pâlir la france oui
oui non bon j'en ai fait mon deuil et
dix ans plus tard
attendait d'eux mans 68 oui en avril en
juillet oui vous avez raison c'est ça on
est soixante huit lors d'une kermesse au
quartier latin j'ai fait la connaissance
du jeune chanteur peter d'as
de sa a droit comme tout le monde
je me suis séparé deux larrons serait
pour l'aider dans son lard j'ai vendu le
château des frondes pas peur pour
collaborer à la révolution culturelle de
la chanson france
et puis il est parti il est parti pour
les usa pour la nouvelle new york
et puis plus rien le petit [ __ ]
voilà cher m je vous ai tout dit je n'ai
plus rien une femme de moulard au
flat
et le gouvernement n'a rien fait pour me
venir en aide
quoi le code le code des pensions et
riscle 45 48
et je peux choisir la pension la plus
avantageuse isolément
henri tu plaisantes ou quoi
mais alors il n'y a pas de problème je
suis la veuve du colonel sigismond
bertrand de la brême où mon premier mari
on est toujours fidèle à ses premières
amours
pardon souple ce soir oui sous peu
c'est rohmer
[Applaudissements]
ne quittez pas
[Musique]
soutenu la
rouge pas ma mine
[Musique]
et
allo
alexandre alexandrov et tous et vous
dînez avec vous ce soir à rezé
je ne voudrais jamais vous dire que je
vous ai entendu un soir de 8 heures à 10
heures jet harris
cela vous ferait de la peine je le sais
vous êtes trop sensible
je ne peux pas vous dire non plus que je
suis au courant de votre sortait avec
cette fausse blonde que vous trouviez si
vulgaire
cela vous diminuerait à mon endroit
vous avez trop de fierté
bien sûr je ne peux pas vous dire non
plus votre démarche cette façon de dire
je roule ou vos médard
me mais le coeur en joie
que votre aire de conquérant votre
absence de répartie mais entendu que
vous avez sur toute chose
la tranquillité et le vide qui émane de
vaud mais merde à chaque instant
bien sûr je ne peux pas vous dire non
plus que vous êtes samus pensée pour
toutes les femmes derrière votre haute
stature et votre présence
musclée
une toute petite poupée que nous aimons
sortir ceux ci après une rude journée de
labeur ou tout simplement par
désoeuvrement
n'avait rien couperet
alexandre alexander vik
je sais tout à présent c'est ainsi que
je vous aide
à propos j'ai vu le cabriolet qui vous
fait tellement envie je crois avoir
toutes les facilités pour vous l'os
pour vous obtenu
vous viendrez dîner avec moi ce soir
merci
le
nouvel
essai mais qu'est ce que c'est mais
qu'est ce que ça vous parle j'avoue
verbales mais non non c'est pas moi bah
non non non enfin c'est pas gentil tu
sais que j'ai horreur des horreurs
gérard de la télévision j'aimais les
coulisses c'est tout c'est tout je suis
nue et des devs
s'il fait très froid dans les coulisses
nantis non tout va assis dans les
couloirs ces eaux là là là tous là la
grippe tout ça vous monte j'ai fait une
sorte de petite mixture je me laisse
aller et puis alors j'ai mis l'individu
citrouille sur est bien gardé il faut
qu'on clac et c'est très
bien parce que je préfère ici c'est tout
blanc papa tu sais pas vous moi d'abord
de leur frère depuis je fais peur aux
enfants
si c'est le cas que j'aurais aimé jouer
mais jérémy grimm blanche-neige s'il a
peut-être
sinon c'est pas raisonnable et puis cela
nous
change de couleur
fait ça y est c'est fini
[Musique]
oui varie
alors j'entends rien quoi
adrien
pas
ses morts
ah non non non dd c'est bon quoi ah bon
tu m'entends ah ouais bon ouais on est
installé ouais t'as un grillon bon alors
tu donnes bas on habite à dugny 3 unis
bah comme ça s'écrit
sans wendel sont battues 2 boulevard de
la source lotissement 16 bâtiments un
escalier b rez-de-chaussée porte 1094
ouais ça fait du monde à droite en
montrant
si on a le cancer ouais bah alors tu la
connais pas ma maurice et l'or même si
elle est près de la même religion que la
nôtre alors elle m'a donné la baraque
barak à la ben
ouais j'étais bien contente d'aider
aussi mais manque quand même elle vous
est ce que ça veut dire parce que des
dix mois on s'est parfois alors
louisette alafé laisse pas les dernières
elle doit connaître
oui merci quoi
on est très très bien la ville j'ai par
le visa qui on se croirait presque à la
cantine j'entendais toujours
c'est rien
n'en sais rien c'est le passage ouais
mais j'oubliais te dire du balcon de la
cuisine tu vois non et là moi je vois
les avions atterrir sur la piste juste à
côté du oui madame
ça change un peu de sabre mais on peut
par balle c'est toute sa vie à sa brawn
a
obligé pour tous dit parce que de
l'autre côté j'ai quand même la chance
d'avoir le périphérique juste en dessous
alors tu penses avec les éclairages de
la route on voit très bien comme ça pas
besoin d'allumer la lumière quelle
économie même le matin tu sais que dd se
lève tous les matins à 5 heures 30
pourquoi trop nous
parce que c'est l'heure du baba cool et
le premier vol de lutter
quoi macro à non je connais pas non
c'est ma voisine du 14e team de quoi
les gens sont très gentils avec très peu
de recul est-ce que j'ai foutu nous
andrier je le vois pas pourquoi qui nous
fait la gueule là y'a quoi bah oui
d'aider aussi entre est lui qui marque
donc le père de barils à bois trophy
parfois il a les pieds tout gonflé
forcément on est seront faits par le sol
dis donc je vais te faire une surprise
dimanche prochain c'est à l'émission de
radio à 50 32 je t'envoie venise et
bretagne par tino rossi 7e rappellera
pas des comptes à s'auto rate pas je
penserai bien-être en même temps que le
bât nha coûts directs c'est la même
heure et ben voilà la petite mort voilà
toutes les nouvelles de temps brasserie
ben ouais non c'est pas d'avion salon
cdd qui va prendre ça n'oublie pas mâche
pas encore tout vu s'allumer bon bah
écoute t'embrasse bien être la madeleine
bourgeois by
manager oublie de dire j'ai j'ai acheté
trois bouts la teinture aux pour la robe
de l'os en coupant les branches et bah
je pense pouvoir la ressortir pour
l'arbre de noël notre prochaine sortie à
la mutualité
j'espère qu'elle va bien pour nous
malgré les tâches sous les bras
à la team brazil bon a dit longeur
accroche pas ce que ça va te coûter de
fortune tout ça voilà tout va bien je
t'embrasse
tout va bien tout va bien joli
bonnet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]